the Christmas season and Christmas Eve
and Christmas Day in particular are kind
of a Bittersweet and sometimes
Melancholy time for me for reasons that
I'll share with you in just a bit you
could say that they stem from a contrast
between the present time and a past that
I experienced really from my childhood
all the way through into my late 20s
centered around a particular place and
my large family the LA Marie's family
and all of the interactions and joy and
warmth and connections that we had in
that time all the things that we did
together so I'm going to tell you the
story about that it's not the entire
story of Christmas time for me there's
many other memories as well but
I think this may be something
interesting for all of you and it's
certainly been on my mind lately as we
lead up to Christmas and I was thinking
about this in particular last night we
went to kind of a fancy event where they
had these four carolers and a musician a
Pianist from one of the local operas the
Florentine Opera you know so there were
these uh great singers and they were
singing Christmas songs and you know I
was sitting next to my wife with my
mother-in-law on the other side and
we're all kind of like you know
listening to the music and I felt myself
near tears with some of the songs
because I was thinking about all the
things they reminded me of in these
these much earlier times from you know
four or five
in some cases is close to three well
almost three decades ago
so my family
on my mother's side the family I was
adopted into is a large French Canadian
family called the lemrez and uh you know
there were a lot of uh brothers and
sisters in my grandparents generation
and they you know they were born in the
United States but as French speakers and
many of them brought wives and husbands
down from Quebec and sort of continued
things and eventually they wound up in
the 1930s in Chicago living on a
particular block that was all mostly
French Canadian and Menominee Indian and
they could all speak French together and
my mom didn't actually learn English
until she went off to grammar school and
she was either five or six and so this
was kind of a common thing and the
family bought land in Indiana way back
in that time and they would take the
kids out there and then eventually when
the older people were retiring and
leaving the city and sort of Fanning out
they saw the farm and a number of my
grandfather's generation bought land and
built houses all the same Wasa house uh
connected together with two of them by a
four-car garage and a deck and stuff
like that and that is where we had
except for a few years the family
Christmases there was one exception that
I've actually talked about in another
video when my mom had an operation so we
had Christmas at our place everybody
converged there and that's the story
where we raised a little kitten to give
to my grandfather to be the new Cricket
cat but
for the most part it meant driving down
to Northwestern Indiana just north of
Roselawn off of Highway 65 and we would
generally show up on Christmas Eve
rarely the day before because you know
oftentimes my my dad had to work or
after he died my mom would have to work
and
so we would have this big drive down and
we would leave our house near Wales
Wisconsin get on to 94 take that through
Milwaukee through what we call the
spaghetti bowl back then all these roads
going off in different directions
including the bridge to nowhere that you
may have seen in The Blues Brothers
movie and then down past Racine and
Kenosha into the Chicagoland area
oftentimes we would stop for McDonald's
in Racine or we would stop at one of the
Oasis along 94. and then we had a big
decision do we take as my mom called it
the damn Ryan which actually the Dan
Ryan going down through the city or the
toll road 294 uh you know or the Skyway
and anyway we'd get to Northwestern
Indiana and then eventually take Highway
65 down and you know then we would get
off on 10 take County Line Road North
and pretty soon we'd be at the turn off
for Shayla Marie's the lemres compound
and when you drive in very often there'd
be you know snow and stuff like that the
trip could take us you know on a really
good day it would take us three and a
half to four hours sometimes it could
take us quite a bit longer but we would
get there and then we would pull up and
you know we'd have our presence in the
car and we'd have our stuff packed and
we parked the car and we'd get out and
then we would go in and we would always
go in through the same door the door
that everybody went through a basement
door going into each of these these
homes my grandfather and grandmother's
home and my uncle Hubert and Aunt
Teresa's home by the way Uncle Hubert
and Grandpa were brothers and Grandma
and Aunt Therese were sisters
they um they had these Wausau homes and
then each had a basement a cinder block
basement uh generally you know only
semi-finished Uncle yubert's actually
had all these lot these books in it it
was a vast library and there was a you
know stove downstairs and a bathroom
downstairs but you know cinder block
walls and all sorts of random Furniture
in there including a church pew you know
that had come from a place that we often
used to take maps on and then there was
a garage that was a four-car garage
connecting the two and so it was like
one big complex and we'd go in through
that door and there'd always be somebody
at the door once we went in greeting us
we'd all go in my dad my mom my sister
and I and
um you know we would uh hear this big
cheer ah they're here you know and then
people would be coming and hugging us
Aunt honey would be there pinching our
cheeks and uh you know doing various
stuff it was usually the late afternoon
when that would happen and the smell of
food would hit you because things were
being prepared upstairs and downstairs
for the big family feast
and you know you'd sit in there and
everyone would you know start talking to
you it was nice and warm there was a
wood burning stove in the basement right
as soon as you walked in so you'd smell
the wood and feel the heat coming off of
it and you know we would go in and
eventually things would get sort of set
up you could say and people would shake
hands and hug and stuff like that and
then things would get underway and for
for some of us that meant doing some
chores some cooking you know I might be
peeling potatoes which then would be
cooked boiled and then riced with a
special ricer Grandpa at that time was
the person in charge of cooking the
oyster stew which sometimes I would help
out with but a lot of the time we would
just be enjoying ourselves you know I
have a soda which was kind of a thing
for special occasions and start talking
with the relatives who we hadn't seen
for a while my cousins my uncles my
aunts you know various other other
relatives
maybe Grandpa's twin brother father art
the viatorian would be there as well and
Uncle Hubert would you know come up and
give you a handshake and a hug and want
to know what you've been reading and
stuff like that and so there'd be like
all this stuff going on and you know you
help bring in the the food that we
brought and uh you know the the
suitcases with the stuff that we had you
know for the few days that we were going
to be staying there and then
um you know the the presents as well
would would typically go upstairs and
then we would have our meal and
and Uncle Hubert's basement uncle
youbert and tunnies they had this
massive table that had come from a
factory it was like this thick wood and
it extended so far that until the family
got too big almost everybody could sit
at that table
very long with all sorts of mismatched
chairs uh we're never you know big
standing on ceremony kind of family when
it came to that and then the food would
come out and there would be you know a
celery that had been cut that we could
all have as kind of a snack and there
would be cheeses and then there would be
all the different dishes grandpas
oysters soup coming from their time when
they lived in New England for a while
the tutsiai the Canadian meat pie Aunt
honey would have made several of those
some of them some people would eat that
with molasses or ketchup I like to eat
it just by itself and there would be ham
and there would be potatoes rice
potatoes with gravy and all sorts of
other things that people would bring and
you know there was wine poured us kids
often had to drink wine whether we
wanted to or not just a little Juice
Glass you know and we would eat and talk
and catch up and and until everyone was
completely sated and then we would bring
out the the cake the bush to Noel the
Christmas log somebody would always make
it different people try their hands at
it and then we would slice into it and
um
then you know sometimes we would go for
a walk my uncle aim liked to lead walks
where we would cross the County Line
Road and go into the subdivision and
look at all of the Christmas lights very
often it would have snowed and it would
be so cold that sometimes icicles would
form in his beard in his mustache until
I was much older I didn't have one I do
remember like trying to grow a mustache
back and uh high school and my uncle
John calling me dirt lip because of it
because it didn't grow in quite so thick
as as this right it was actually quite
sparse
but we have these rituals and so we you
know we would go for a walk to work off
some of the food and meanwhile the
adults some of them besides Uncle aim
who's leading us right would
um get the the next things ready so you
know all the presents would be brought
out including the ones that were from
Santa and then you know we would come
back into the warm uh basement and
um then we would hear Jingle Bells from
upstairs right and the the little kids
my cousins and myself as well and my
sister when we were little kids we were
we were the oldest of of the cousins
um they would be like Santa's here right
so everybody tear upstairs and go into
the the living room which had its own
fireplace which would be going as well
and the the living room and joined the
the kitchen and the dinette and stuff
like that and so you know people would
have drinks High balls were quite
popular dealer at the time and then
everybody would sit around on the
couches or chairs or on the fireplace
ledge or you know sometimes on the floor
they'd bring out the kitchen chairs as
well
and then we'd begin opening presents on
Christmas Eve and it would go in order
from the youngest all the way to the
oldest and then begin again so a young
person had opened up a present and oh
it's so great right and then it would be
the next youngest person and the next
youngest person all the way up to Uncle
Hubert who was the oldest of us all and
then it would begin again and some of
the presents were you know for the kids
coming from Santa or from their
godparents or from other people like
that and very often we're giving people
presents like I would give my you know
God Parents presents and I would get I
would get presents from them my uncle
John and my aunt bib
um you know and we'd go on like that
parents would have presents for their
children and vice versa and people would
be giving each other things sometimes
they were joke gags like you'd open it
up and a snake would pop out or you know
when Grandpa one time burnt up a lot of
property okay on our land uh the gag
gift was of course a fire extinguisher
and so it was it was stuff like that and
it was a lot of fun
you know Antoni would typically have
something that she had knitted for us
like a a you know
um a scarf or a stocking cap a talk
right but sometimes it would be like she
actually knitted me a Star Wars blanket
one year when she knew that I was like
super into Star Wars and so we'd have
this this vast thing and and then it
would be time to decide who's going to
midnight mass because we did have to go
to mass right and it was a good way of
like getting it in and getting it over
with so I I typically would go unless I
was too tired and I was falling asleep
in which case we would go the next day I
would tag along with somebody if my
parents had gone to midnight mass I
could go with an uncle or Aunt or
Grandpa or Grandma or Anthony or uncle
eubert or you know any of the the others
that were there
and then the the day would come to a
close and so we we had a lot of our
Christmas already in on Christmas Eve
and then Christmas Day could just be
relaxing
hanging out with everybody having fun
you know we had all sorts of leftovers
from the day before
we could have stayed at Uncle ubert and
Antony's or we might stay at Uncle Bib
and Uncle Scott's across the way or we
might be staying with grandpa and
grandma
it varied from year to year to year but
Christmas day everybody would wake up
when they felt like it and we'd have
breakfast and then we would we would get
together and do things if there was snow
we would often take walks out into the
fields that you know my uh my family
owned and we we let out to Farmers but
of course in the winter it's completely
fallow I might make a snow fort or we
might make snowmen or things like that
Uncle Hubert had a very extensive
library in his basement because he was a
great bibliophile I've talked about him
elsewhere as well so we might cuddle up
in the nice warm cozy uh basement you
know with the wood stir stove going
listening you know smelling the the
smell of of the food that's being
reheated or new food being cooked
listening to some music and just reading
a book until you'd fall asleep or you
know a lot of the people would play
cards my grandpa loved cribbage and
Scott my dad aim would play cribbage
Aunt Mary would play cribbage as well
and I learned to play cribbage so we
would all you know swap off sometimes
we'd play you know three-handed or
four-handed right or even five-handed
cribbage that was kind of an interesting
challenge
we'd also play pinochle that was one of
the favorite games of the family and I
learned how to play it as well and I got
pretty pretty good at it you know and we
we might do other things you know by the
time that I got older you know on
Christmas day around noon we'd start
having some some beers you know as we're
we're playing and of course we'd be
smoking cigarettes and stuff like that a
lot of people smoked back then and as I
I've remarked in my previous video about
Cricket
um The Christmas kitten Cricket uh was
was born in Wisconsin and we raised him
a little bit and then gave him to my
grandpa and he was an inside well he was
an outside cat who came inside when it
was really cold and he could hang out in
the garage so I'd come out and sit with
him and pet him and you know kind of
catch up with him he was a great great
old cat who always remembered me and I
always looked forward to seeing him and
there was just so much
festivity and just kind of quiet
camaraderie and
um being there within the The Matrix of
the large family that we all belong to
that was um joyous
and you know it was something I looked
forward to every year even when
I was you know living on my own working
as a security guard you know I'd catch a
ride with my mom or my sister when I
didn't have a car and get down there I
mean it did it was a little bit more
somber after my dad passed away but one
of the good things about having a large
family is that there's so much comfort
that you get in it and there was so much
love going around all the time within
that that family
conveyed in so many different ways from
Uncle Uber talking with us about books
or playing cards with people or the
presents that we made and and bought and
gave to each other to the food that we
put on the table to the the sense that
we were all here together once again
there were other family gatherings you
know Easter was another big time but
Christmas was particularly important I I
would say throughout my childhood and
well into my 20s
um
throughout graduate school so these are
some of the things I could talk for
hours and hours and hours about
different particular incidents or you
know other things that we did that were
particularly uh interesting or relevant
or poignant but I'm going to cut it
short here and just say that
it's because of the goodness the
the
love and the companionship and the
mutual interest and all of these other
things that I got to enjoy the wonderful
time of Christmas
that
um lacking that since the family has
dispersed and you know people are living
in different places and are busy and the
oldest generation is all gone my
grandparents generation and even you
know
my aunts and uncles
um my mother died a long time ago Uncle
aim died during the covid epidemic not
of covid but of other things even that
generation has kind of hollowed out
we don't have that as a a shared
experience anymore and I remember it and
Christmas music and festivities remind
me of it and I'm not complaining I was
extraordinarily lucky and blessed to
have had that experience year after year
after year
but the lack of it
does sometimes you know weigh upon me
and you know I do have the the fortune
of being able to look back on all of
these memories and spend some time
perhaps sitting with some eggnog in
front of a fire somewhere else
reminiscing about my my family and this
wonderful
world of the past not lost to me but no
longer something that I get to
participate in in the present
so that is my little reminiscence about
Christmas time among the lemuries